like another toxic fandom i can think of
that it's just like jumping up
who are we gonna piss off like like
again let's just piss off everyone we're
gonna piss off everybody
who haven't we pissed off do we have any
more people do we have readers
okay so because like i don't even count
them
is that even a fan base i don't even
know no because like i didn't realize
how passionate they were
until tower of god started airing right
and then i remember
making a tower of god video and like
when i tweeted it out or anytime i would
tweet
anything else about tower of god it was
the most
toxic like twitter chain you could ever
think of
yeah where people like tower of god fans
are that dedicated fandom
right and from what i've seen a lot of
the webtoon fan base are the same
because i've seen
i've seen like equally with like the god
of high school fandom as well
where they will defend the show as like
the greatest piece of literature that's
ever been made right and i'm like yeah i
like tower of god yeah you know i've
gone to flight school i haven't read the
i haven't read the webtoon so that could
be better i don't know
um i think the anime is pretty mediocre
as it is yeah but like
they they will like go to war to like
make sure
everyone knows how good this web tune is
i'm really scared now because i'm pretty
sure next season we're getting the noble
s anime right
which basically completes the trifecta
of like the the
webtoon yeah right try because you know
when you have like a slight problem
with like or like a slight criticism
with like this certain anime or show or
manga
and then you make like a tweet about it
yeah and then the billion [ __ ] tweets
you get to be like
um excuse me yeah no this criticism is
wrong
oh my god and that's that's like what
i've seen with like webtoons fans
like times 100 really yeah or or at
least like
or at least with tower of god because
like that was my experience with tower
of god whales like i like tower of god
yeah but then i've read like the
comments chains and a lot of it just
really put me off
like the tower of god fandom you know i
never got that at all
in my head i was just like damn this got
a [ __ ] good soundtrack
that's all i had i was like oh it's
kevin kevin you did good
fandom you know [ __ ] those guys who
needs oxygen man they're
all stuck up who haven't we pissed off
yet then wait is there a good fandom
no no because the more i go through it
i'm like love life garbage
ban garbage every single fairy tale
fairy tale oh my god fair share is awful
fairy tale man it's like the people who
like fairy tale
are the ones who kept those mats you
know the kids with the town yeah yeah
yeah they're the people who kept those
and still use them you know
i have little cars go around i remember
i remember one time
i remember one time there was this
[ __ ] like it i think it was supposed
to be a smear campaign against me right
because you said the fairy tale was
garbage because i said that fairy tale
was garbage in one of my let's fight
videos and
there was a moment on instagram where
people were like
tweeting out oh like posting this like
picture of like natsu and lucy
and it was like protect fairy tale from
the anime man
and there was like 30 people on
instagram being like yes
let's protect our favorite show because
some dude on the internet said it was a
garbage show and i'm just like
oh my god all i said was that this show
sucks like
it's like just chill like chill out is
it a natural occurrence that at a
certain age you just stop giving a [ __ ]
if someone hates on what you like or is
it a
is it a thing that some people have it
it's just because i don't i genuinely
don't know anyone our age
who gets that angry about do you um
i don't know i don't i mean like i like
to have like
arguments yeah no arguments or like
debating [ __ ] i love you
talking out of my ass and getting angry
at jerry about the back of no doubt but
yeah like
that's not like actually like i'm not
going to be offended by it all right
i mean because we're friends right but
i'm not going to on twitter get actually
angry at someone because
i mean a lot of the context and the
humor is lost if i do yeah yeah exactly
i feel like on twitter especially which
i feel like we're pulling most of this
up like most of our yeah this is
normally coming from twitter
yeah i'd say 90 of what i see has come
from twitter it's just not like
not the right platform for this kind of
like debate
and argument like like like i said who's
ever changed their opinion because of a
[ __ ]
tweet you know what i mean you don't
have enough characters to make a
poignant argument
no um that can i can really and i'm not
gonna sit through a [ __ ] like seven
tweet thread right like
the first thing you think when you get
like uh uh like what a
[ __ ] 20-page paragraph your immediate
thought is not to like
i'm going to consider what they've said
so you're like how do i immediately
counter this it's your first
thought on twitter it always is it's
everyone's first yeah right of course so
it's like what's the [ __ ] point
like yeah you just you know don't don't
[ __ ] watch melody
melio just touch up a girl who [ __ ]
cares
if you enjoy it then cool but just be
aware that there are people out there
who don't think that way
right who don't agree with the fact that
it's not a personality trait to touch
women
just saying i'm gonna say it i'm just
gonna say it
i just think it's stupid yeah it is why
does why does meliotis need to do it
i don't know i still want to i wake up
in a cold sweat at night and i'm like
why do you wake up like millionaires did
in the [ __ ] yeah i mean i i
[Laughter]
i just think it's because of like when
uh when
when when did they originally come out
like it was like mid 2000's right or was
it okay in midtooth no because
remember that remember this time in the
mid 2000s where
entire character quirks was oh let's
trip over and touch an anime girl like
literally every harem protagonist yeah
literally every horror protagonist that
was like
there's a difference between tripping up
there and being like
true true true like as a
as an adult male an adult monkey-brained
male yeah
i watched that and i sat there and i
thought who is this appealing to this
character trait like i'm wondering who
do you know because i don't [ __ ] know
it's got to be 12 yards right it's got
to be
that's how like most of my arguments are
down like who likes this 12 year old
must be
probably isn't but to my head no adult
who's functioning in society
it's not appealing to those over the age
of 18. do you like that meliodas touches
people
if so can you tell me why because i'm
genuinely curious like what about it is
fun
like yeah like like i can understand if
you don't have a problem with it but
like if you actively like
enjoy it like that's a good question
like yeah that's what i'm generally
curious like hell yeah meliotis you feel
up that because like i said i don't give
a [ __ ] it's just kind of like smelling a
bad thought like i'm like [ __ ] it ugh
disgusting carry on but like i don't
care like it's not gonna stop me from
watching it i just think it's dumb
i don't know i mean it's it's like the
bad animation is more likely to stop you
from watching yeah that that's really
worse that's way worse
yeah that's that's a way worse that's a
way better reasons than watch [ __ ]
watching
god they what did they do to i'm sorry
seven deadly sins fans they did you
dirty i've i think
what this episode has given me the
realization of is that if you put
the blank fandom and you put any anime
in that blank
it's probably going to be a [ __ ] fan oh
yeah i mean as long as a fandom exists
it's probably going to suck in some way
yeah think of any fandom and
you'll find annoying ass [ __ ] memes
or dumb [ __ ] they say
so if you are a fan of any anime in
general don't take what we said
personally we just like to talk [ __ ]
yeah out of our ass
we hate all fandoms even none of this is
serious if you're a dragon ball fan
please don't think
that you can't talk to me uh you can't
uh actually
you can as long as it's not about dragon
ball